اعلن الجيش الاسرائيلي مقتل مطلق النار
على الحدود المصريه الاسرائيليه وقال ان
قواته ما زالت تعمل على تمشيط المنطقه من
ناحيتها قالت مصادر اسرائيليه ان جنديين
من الجيش الاسرائيلي اصيبا في تبادل
لاطلاق النار على الحدود مع مصر صباح
اليوم وكان وزير الدفاع الاسرائيلي
مع قاده الجيش على خلفيه التطورات التي
شهدتها الحدود على مقربه من معبر نيسان
العوجه منذ ساعات الصباح حيث دفع الجيش
الاسرائيلي بتعزيزات شملت مروحيات قتاليه
شاركت في عمليات تمشيط وبحث عن عناصر خليه
مسلحه اشتبه انها تسللت من سيناء المصريه
عبر الحدود كانوا يحاولون تهريب مخدرات
بقيمه نحو 600 الف دولار وتم احباط
محاولتهم
مره اخرى الى وليد العمري ربما لصباح بعض
النقاط
نحاول ان نفهم معك ايضا لماذا يفرض
التعتيم الاعلامي وليد في مثل هذه المرحله
وايضا ما الذي يفهم من التصريح بان هذا
الحدث استثنائي طالما ان هذه المنطقه
منطقه العوجه تشهد عمليات تهريب سابقه
لماذا يوصف الان بانه استثنائي
اسرائيل اعطته صبغه امنيه منذ اللحظه
الاولى كما نقلت الاذاعه العبريه عن مسؤول
الامني كبير والذي وصفه بانه حادث امني
خطير لكن من الملابسات التي تم الافراج
عنها حتى الان فان الموضوع بدا نحو
السادسه والنصف من صباح هذا اليوم في
احباط محاوله تهريب مخدرات بنحو مليوني
شيكل اسرائيلي 600 الف دولار تقريبا
واعتبرت بانها عمليه كبيره جدا ثم بعد
فتره وجيزه بعد بضع بعد ساعات قليله كان
هناك نبا عن اصابه اسرائيليين شخصين قال
الجانب الاسرائيلي تبين لاحقا انهم من
الجنود من جنود الوحده التي كما يبدو
احبطت محاوله التهريب لكن الموضوع تطور
بعد ان تبين ان هناك كما يبدو مسلح
شخص مسلح قد تسلل من الجانب المصري او انه
كان يتواجد قرب الحدود وان هناك نظير له
على الجانب المصري هذا الشخص هو ما اعترف
الجيش الاسرائيلي بانه تبادل اطلاق النار
معه في عمليه التنشيط التي تبعت كل هذه
التطورات
وقتله في نهايه المطاف لكنه يشتبه بوجود
شخص اخر ربما انسحب الى داخل الاراضي
المصريه وكان هو الاخر مسلحا اعطاء
الموضوع صبغه بانه حادث امني وليس جنائي
منذ اللحظه الاولى من الواضح بان هناك لدى
الجيش الاسرائيلي ما يريد اخفاءه بالمرحله
الاولى ودفع بكل هذه التعزيزات ليست هذه
المره الاولى التي يتم فيها
الصدام مع
مهربين في تلك المنطقه هذا تكرر كثيرا
اخره كان في سبتمبر الماضي وقد قتل شاب
بدوي من منطقه النقب قالت اسرائيل انه كان
ضمن عمليه التهريب ولكن لم تقم بمثل هذا
التصعيد او مثل هذه اللهجه حول وجود
وجود صبغه امنيه ثانيا ما يثير علامات
السؤال الكثيره هو المشاورات الامنيه
العسكريه التي اجراها وزير الدفاع غلنت مع
رئيس الاركان ومع ضباط الكبار والامر
الثالث انهم دفعوا بتعزيزات تشملوا على
مروحيات قتاليه الى تلك المنطقه واليوم هو
يوم السبت وعاده هذا المعبر اغلب الاحيان
يكون يوم السبت يكون مغلق هو مخصص فقط
لحركه التجاره وليس لحركه الافراد
فواضح بان لدى الجيش الاسرائيلي كان على
الاقل على مدار الساعات الماضيه او الجهات
الامنيه الاسرائيليه ما يريد اخفاءه الى
ان يفرج نهائيا عن كافه المعلومات التي من
المفترض انها تلقي المزيد من الضوء حول
حقيقه ما وصل واذا ما كان هذا الحادث
جنائي بالفعل فقط ام انه ذا طابع امني لان
سيناء كما هو معروف وخلال السنوات الماضيه
غالبا ما جرت بعض عمليات اطلاق النيران من
داخل الجانب المصري او محاولات التسلل او
تهريب اسلحه اي مستوى من الاستنفار وصل
اليه الجيش الاسرائيلي حتى الان منذ بدء
هذه العمليه وليد
لنقيم ربما مستوى التعامل ايضا ومساوى
تقدير خطوره ما جرى بالنسبه لاسرائيل
المصرح به هو انه دفع بتعزيزات عسكريه
كبيره من الجيش اشتملت على قوات من
اليابسه وكذلك على مروحيات قتاليه التي
توجهت الى تلك المنطقه وانها شاركت في
عمليه تبادل اطلاق للنار وقعت في ساعات
الظهر اي بعد نحو خمسه الى ست ساعات من
الموعد الذي قال فيه انه احبط محاولات
تهريب مخدرات عبر الحدود في منطقه قريبه
من معبر نتانا العوجه يشار الى ان هذا هذه
الحدود الطويله وهي تصل الى نحو 2008 كيلو
مترات لكن الجدار او السياج الامني
بارتفاع خمسه امتار وبطول 241 كيلومترا
واطول من الحدود نفسها هو محصن بشكل جيد
جدا لكن منطقه العوجه بحكم وجود شوارع
لحركه الشاحنات هذه كلها تشير ان يبدو ان
من اراد التسلل او اراد التهريب حاول
استغلال يوم السبت من اجل استخدام هذه
المنطقه والنفاذ الى داخل الجانب
الاسرائيلي من الحدود مع العلم ان عليها
رقابه
مشدده للغايه الحشودات او التعزيزات التي
ارسلت حسب ما هو مصرح به بالدرجه الاولى
وحسب ما افاد به بعض شهود العيان انهم
كانوا يسمعون ليس فقط اطلاق نيران وحركه
المروحيات او هديرها وانما كانوا يستمعون
ايضا في بعض الاحيان الى قصف قصف مدفعي او
قصف الدبابات لان العمليه تركزت عمليه
التمشيط من جانب الاسرائيلي تركزت في كافه
المنطقه المتاخمه بمنطقه نتسانا والمتاخمه
ايضا لمنطقه المعبر ومنطقه الحدود باتجاه
منطقه رفح اي
باتجاه منطقه الشمال الغربي لهذه الحدود
الحدود من نقطه وقوع هذا الحادث الى تلاقي
الحدود بين المصريه الفلسطينيه الاس الشرق
مدينه رفح او في منطقه كرم ابو سالم هناك
نحو اربعين كيلو مترا وهناك شارع يسير
بمحاذاه هذه الحدود ليصل ايضا الى منطقه
معبر كرب ابو سالم الذي من خلاله يتم
ادخال البضائع الى الى مصر
واضح بانه كانوا قلقين بشكل خاص من ان
يكون لذلك علاقه اما بالمقاومه في غزه ام
بالمجموعات المسلحه في داخل سيناء وليد
بالبقارنه مع العمليات السابقه ونحن
تحدثنا عن حادثه ديسمبر 22 وكان هناك
حادثه في مارس الماضي فرت كما تقول
المعلومات الوارده من الجانب الاسرائيلي
المهربون من مواجهه الجيش والقوا بما معهم
من ما يحوزونه من مخدرات حينها في بعض
المناطق لكن المختلف هنا ويثير تساؤلات
وعن هذه الاستفهامات نسالك ما ابرز
الاستفهامات حول هذه العمليه من حيث ان
هناك اشتباك
واشتباك على مستوى عالي استخدام ايضا
للاسلحه الثقيله ربما حتى طائره تدخلت
والحديث فقط عن شخص هل كانت الاصابه خارج
الحدود ام تمكن من النفاذ الى داخل الحدود
وقتل فهناك بالمقارنه عديد من الاستفهامات
حول ما جرى
بالفعل هي كذلك في المرات السابقه وفي
اغلبها خاصه الاخيره منها كانوا يسارعون
الى الاعلان انهم احبطوا عمليه او محاوله
تهريب مخدرات وقتلوا مهربين هذه المره كان
هناك تعتيم وتكتم شديد جدا الشخص الذي قتل
او الذي يقول الجيش بانه من المهربين وانه
كان مسلحا وتبادل معه واطلاق النار قتل في
الجانب الاسرائيلي من الحدود اي في منطقه
في عمق
صحراء النقب في منطقه مقابله لمنطقه
نتسانه العوجه لكن الاشتباه بوجود شخص اخر
ربما في الجانب المصري هذه النقطه ماذا
تزالت تقتضي التوضيح لانه من غير واضح ما
اذا كان هناك شخص من الجانب المصري قد زود
او قد سر هرب المخدرات او الاسلحه او اي
شيء اخر الى الشخص الذي قابله على الجانب
الاسرائيلي ام ان هذا الشخص قد تسلل من
مصر الى داخل الجانب الاسرائيلي حتى الان
ثانيا منذ اللحظه الاولى التي اعلن فيها
عن هذا الحدث وتطوراته كان هناك ميزتان في
الموقف الاسرائيلي سواء المعلن رسميا او
المعلن بشكل غير او المسرب بشكل غير رسمي
الاول بان جهات امنيه وصفت الحادث بانه
امني خطير جدا ثانيا الموضوع الاخر بانهم
تكتموا حتى على المصابين الاثنين كانوا
يقولون ان اصيب شخصين ثم تسربت معلومات
بان الشخصين هما من جنود الجيش الاسرائيلي
الامر الثالث الذي لابد من اضافته وهذا
يشير الى ان الامور مختلفه عما كانت
المرات السابقه والسرعه التي تراس فيها
وزير الدفاع جلنت اجتماعا لمشاورات امنيه
مع رئيس هيئه الاركان وايضا ضباط اخرين
كبار هذه العوامل الثلاثه كانت هامه في
الماضي كان احد
نقاط الضعف او ما يقلق اسرائيل هو ان هذه
الحدود تستخدم
تسلل من قبل متسللين قادمين من افريقيا او
من مناطق مختلفه اما للعمل او للعيش في
اسرائيل او هاربين من الاوضاع التي يعيشون
فيها ثم كانت تستخدم تاريخيا لتهريب
المخدرات الان في بعض المراحل ايضا
استخدمت لتتهريب الاسلحه او لتسلل
المسلحين من داخلها الى داخل الصيد ويذكر
بانه كان هناك قد اطلقت صواريخ في بعض
الاحيان على مدينه ايلات على البحر الاحمر
وهي مدينه ساحليه وكان هناك تسلل لمدرعه
مسلحين استولوا على مدرعه تابعه ومجنزره
متابعه للجيش المصري عام 2012 وبعد ان
قتلوا 16 جنديا مصريا في قاعده العسكريه
متاخمه للحدود وتسللوا الى داخل اسرائيل
وقتلتهم اسرائيل بالقصف داخل مدرعتهم بعد
ان كانوا قد قطعوا مسافه في منطقه
كيبوسكرم ابو سالم او تلك المنطقه
للحدود مع شرقيه رفح بحاجه ان وارجو ان
تتمكن انت من النظر في هذا الموضوع بان
هناك حديث عن مقتل جنديين في جيش الدفاع
نتيجه اطلاق النار خلال الحادث الامني على
الحدود مع مصر الحديث حتى الان عن انه في
منطقه اللواء الاقليمي كما يسمونها قتل في
الحادث جندي ومجنده نتيجه اطلاق نار
بالقرب من الحدود وبان جيش الدفاع يقوم
بالتحقيق في ملابسات الحادث ويجري اعمال
تمشيط في المنطقه هل يمكن التاكد من
المصادر الاسرائيليه حول هذه المعلومات
هذا ايضا اذا صح يفسر السبب الذي فرض فيه
الجيش الاسرائيلي حذرا مشددا وتكتم على
المعلومات سواء حول المصابين في البدايه
الذين قال انهم اشخاص ثم تسرب انهم جنود
والان هذه المعلومه التي ترددت خلال
الساعتين الاخرين دون تاكيد هو انه ربما
قتلا فيبدو ان المعلومه على جانب كبير من
الدقه وهو ما يفسر ايضا مساله لماذا فرض
هذا التعتيم بهذه الشده ولماذا كان هناك
تحفظ عاده يسارع الجيش الاسرائيلي الى
اعلان بيان اذا كان قد احبط عمليه سواء
تهريب اسلحه او تهريب
مخدرات لكن هذه المره كان هناك تحفظ نحن
الان نتحدث عن مرور نحو سبع ساعات تقريبا
منذ وقوع بدايه هذا الحدث وهو ما اعلنه
انه احبط خلاله عن محاوله تهريب المخدرات
ثم بعد نحو ساعتين تحدث عن وقوع اصابات
بين اشخاص قال اصيب شخصين ولكن كان واضح
بان التكتم الذي فرضه كان بهدف اولا
لاخفاء طبيعه ما جرى وثانيا لاخفاء طبيعه
الاصابات وما اذا كانوا من الجنود من انهم
من الجيش هذا تاكد وان اصاباتهم كانت
خطيره تاكد الان قد يكون هذه المعلومه
ايضا تفسر معلومه وليد جاءت نعم هي جاءت
على في حساب الذي قال بانه قتل جنديين في
جيش الدفاع نتيجه اطلاق النار اعلن ذلك
هذا صحيح اذا الناطق العسكري اعلن ذلك في
حسابها او في تصريح هذا يكون قد قطع الشك
باليقين بهذا الخصوص الجيش الاسرائيلي
مشاهدينا مقتل الجنديين نتيجه اطلاق نار
خلال حادث امني على الحدود مع مصر وكما
ذكر في حساب اذرع على تويتر بانه جندي
ومجنده قتل في هذه العمليه